-Here's how it works.
Each round you're gonna
choose a category,
then take turns naming things
in that category.
Your clock counts down.
-My what does?
-Your clock. Your clock.
-Oh.
-C-L -- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Your clock counts down.
-'Cause I was gonna say
that's -- that's a reach.
-Yeah, yeah.
When it's your turn
and whoever's clock runs
out of time first loses.
-What did you say?
-If you can't think
of anything --
-By the way,
I'm quite good at this
because I play this at home
but with mallets.
[ Laughter ]
-It's like Whack-A-Mole.
All right, if you can't think of
anything in the category,
you can bluff
and make something up.
But if your opponent hits
this challenge button here
and calls your bluff,
then they --
-Well, time's up.
[ Laughter ]
Geez.
-Oh, my God.
Well, they have
long instructions.
So basically what happens is
a new category, you say a thing,
you press,
then the timer goes down.
-Oh. Hmm.
-Well, yeah.
Let's take a look at --
-Wait, so after I say it,
then I hit that?
-Yeah, that's correct.
-That's only a challenge.
-Let's just say if I don't
buy you what you said,
I'm gonna hit that.
-Wow. Okay.
-Tonight's categories,
we have...
Oscar winners.
-Ooh.
-Words that rhyme with "play."
Types of balls.
[ Laughter ]
Things that are green,
animals with tails,
and 17th-century
Dutch oil painters.
[ Laughter ]
Marty --
-Let's go with 17th century --
[ Laughter ]
-I don't think that's fair.
-Why don't you pick
the first category?
-Things that are green.
There are 20 seconds
on your clocks.
Marty, when you're ready, name
your first word that rhymes --
things that are green
and then hit your button.
-Lettuce.
-That font.
-Envy.
-Frogs!
-Marijuana.
-Money.
-Your urine sample.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, he challenged you.
He challenged you on that.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-No, it's purple.
[ Laughter ]
Let's go on to another.
Can we --
-A different category.
-We still got 14 seconds left.
-Oh, we go to
a different category.
-Yeah, yeah.
Steve, why don't you --
why don't you pick
the next category?
-Well, I just kind of have to go
with types of balls.
[ Laughter ]
-Why not? Here we go.
-I go first?
-Yeah.
-Beach.
-Rubber.
-Pool.
-Bowling.
-Soccer.
-Football.
-Volleyball. Whoops.
-Balls!
[ Laughter ]
Testicles!
-Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
-Challenge.
[ Buzzer ]
-Wait a second.
-Whoa, prove it.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no. Don't prove it.
Don't prove it.
Just show me. Just show me.
[ Laughter ]
-See?
-Absolutely not.
[ Laughter ]
Steve wins the challenge.
It is time --
-Let's try another category.
-Why not?
-This final round
is worth 50,000 points.
-Wow! How much is a point worth,
I mean, in money?
-Zero.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, 50,000 sounds like a lot.
-I'm going to pick -- these are
things that rhyme with "play."
-Ooh.
-Things that rhyme with "play."
-Who goes first?
-Marty, you will go first.
-Okay, things
that rhyme with "play."
Way.
-Uh...
[ Laughter ]
Gay.
-Hit the button.
-Whoa!
[ Laughter ]
-A play.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
Why not?
-Come on, Mr. Judge!
-Judges?
[ Buzzer ]
No, I think --
judges, I think yes.
"Play" does rhyme with "play."
Congratulations. The winner,
the champion -- Martin Short!
[ Cheers and applause ]
My thanks to Steve Martin,
Martin Short.